mad flavor here in a [ __ ] parking
structure
trying to get my head together Oh
Minneapolis in the house one show
tonight 8 o'clock we're gonna rock that
[ __ ] out I didn't get up at 6:45
in the 4:45 in the morning to come all
the way here to [ __ ] around with your
mother [ __ ] 8 o'clock house economy
I'm smoking some terrific [ __ ] cush
and that's it and that's that it's happy
to be here
it's cloudy but who gives a [ __ ] it's a
beautiful day to be alive whether you're
Minnesota Minneapolis Chicago New York
you know why cuz you're alive
[ __ ] smoking a little King Louie
the third is this [ __ ] that killed
Princess Diana and that's all that
matters we're here we're queer you know
I love you [ __ ] oh yeah
little like smoking a nice number out
here get off the plane and I get to hook
up with you [ __ ] before we get
down to it you understand me sometimes
you got to get down tonight it's that
[ __ ] night eight o'clock if you're
not there shooting yourself
it's like eating wings retrench ain't
gonna work out for you that's what I
hate about plane rides
you can't spark I hit the vapor pen a
couple times and I hate a few stars I
have leftover they took me to where I
needed to be I watched the movie the
accountant not bad Vince been athlete's
a bad [ __ ] but besides that
that's it and that's that three days in
beautiful Minneapolis I cannot wait
these people these Gentiles are looking
at me like what's he doing over there
[ __ ] you don't do a little sparkin [ __ ]
the number of debt you understand me
I'm gonna walk in the Mall of America
get some lego [ __ ] from my daughter see
what they got in there maybe got a
protein shake or something and that's it
you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey loves
you I'm here all weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday but tonight's
the night so that's when we could go
long and [ __ ] around and test out what
the [ __ ] I'm gonna lay down for the rest
of the week have I told you people I
love smoking marijuana
wait keep me posted I'll be around all
day seeing the devil all right stay
black Google Joey lotion